this is chris morris reading for writer
alessandro fellari
in the four years since its debut the
nintendo switch has proven to be a
popular and versatile platform that
blends handheld and console gaming
sensibilities
but with the earlier rumors of a major
enhancement for the switch on the
horizon
it set expectations to some sizeable
levels
so after weeks of online chatter it was
surprising to see the switch oled
instead an upgraded model of the
existing device built on the same
internal components
which wasn't quite the next step forward
that fans were expecting
but after a recent hands-on session with
the new nintendo switch oled
i got to see its upgrades in person
which helped affirm what this new device
is all about
but let's get this out of the way first
is the nintendo switch oled model a must
buy
at 350 honestly that all depends
if you're a first time buyer then the
oled model is certainly a compelling
entry point
but if you're expecting the new switch
to transform the current console into
something different then you're in for
some disappointment
aside from its upgrades the switch oled
is essentially one-to-one with what's
already out there
its peripherals are also interchangeable
with the standard switch model so if you
have joy-con controllers that you want
to keep or stick with the current
docking station with the two
usb ports you can certainly carry them
over to the oled model
what i found most interesting about the
oled model was that it helped bridge the
gap between
the handheld and docked experiences
amping up the way you play the switch
as a handheld during my hands-on session
i brought my current launch era nintendo
switch
along with a ps vita which also features
an oled screen
to make side-by-side comparisons and it
was evident that the new switch is a
noticeable improvement compared to both
devices
compared to the switch and switch lights
lcd screen the oled model's 7-inch
screen better displays light and black
levels which presents a more vivid and
illuminating picture that looks clear
and bright
in motion playing breath of the wild on
the new display really brought a sense
of vibrancy
highlighting the contrasting colours
when overlooking the hyrule landscape
just after the iconic introduction
jumping over to mario kart 8 deluxe the
game's 60 fps visuals looked incredibly
smooth and sharp on the oled display
the new model makes handheld mode look
better than it ever has and it honestly
made me interested in seeing how my
other favorite games like bayonetta 2 or
smash bros ultimate
would look on the new display the
enhanced audio also added a lot to the
sense of ambiance when playing games
compared to the original switch's
smaller speakers the new enhanced
speakers are much
larger improving the sound levels and
range while playing in handheld mode
the oled model also has slight
improvements in additions that give the
console a better optimized design
for instance the sd card slot has been
altered which now appears on a slope to
make slotting cards a bit
easier it also comes in two different
colour schemes one with a black and
white design with a white dock
and another with the traditional neon
blue and red design with a black dock
the key areas in which the switch oled
sees improvements are focused on the
handheld experience
while the switch's handheld mode has
always been convenient it also offers
less than perfect conditions for
experiencing certain games compared to
playing it docked
unfortunately the significant
improvements with the oled model means
the main benefits to come with the new
device will be lost when playing in
docked mode
despite these shortcomings i still came
away from my brief hands-on with the new
model feeling largely relieved left with
the impression that the oled model
offers the best switch handheld
experience available
the new improvements that the oled model
offers for the nintendo switch punctuate
what makes the handheld console such a
fantastic device
the upcoming version follows a familiar
nintendo tradition
of producing improved models for
existing platforms
much like the game boy advance sp and
the new 3ds xl
the switch oled is a clear improvement
upon the current iterations of the
console
elevating the platform's strengths for
portability and flexibility
the new oled model for the switch is not
the true successor for the console
and that's just fine with that said is
it a necessary upgrade for those who are
already comfortable with their switch
not necessarily but i can't deny that i
was impressed with the subtle changes
and improved presentation that the oled
model offered
despite being comfortable with my
current console i can still see myself
making the jump for this new and
improved model because of how well its
new presentation works
the improved handheld experience does
present an enticing offer to trade up to
a new model
but i won't feel too much fomo if i
ultimately decide not to
with all that said go buy metroid dread
when it releases alongside the new
nintendo switch oled
please
[Music]
you